hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
avoiding hurdles in molecular assay
development
i am jennifer woods of labrus and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruz and brought to you
by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation i'd like to
now welcome our speaker
naim nathu new business development
manager
molecular diagnostics naim you may now
begin your presentation
excellent thank you for the introduction
jennifer my name is naim nathu
i am a business development manager at
thermo fisher scientific
supporting molecular diagnostics
so for today we'll start with an
introduction then move to some current
challenges in molecular test development
followed by attributes of improved
enzyme design
methods and enzyme development we'll see
next generation enzymes in action
through some case studies and end off
with quality
and manufacturing capabilities at thermo
fisher scientific
that can routinely be leveraged by our
customers
so here's the workflow from a high level
and it has three
major phases extraction amplification
and detection
if we start with the extraction we can
see that there's a wide variety of
sample input types
and it's critical to be cognizant of
what characteristics and features
come with leveraging a specific sample
input type depending on what your target
is
dna and or rna and you're going to want
to pick a sample extraction method
that is curated to that specific sample
input type
if we jump over to detection for a
minute you can see that there's a wide
variety of ways
to do that downstream analysis but the
meat or the bulk of the conversation
today is going to be around
amplification and this is primarily
broken out into two
major subcategories
on the left-hand side we can see the
quantitative side of amplification the
qpcr
the rtq-pcr it is
a real-time analysis that has the
benefits of accuracy
speed and specificity and it measures
the load of your specific target in this
particular instance
we've called out infectious agents it's
great for things like target detection
target quantitation and genotyping
on the flip side of this we have
isothermal amplification or endpoint pcr
this is more of the qualitative side
of amplification it measures the
presence
or absence of your target of interest
and in this case again
we've called out let's say infectious
agents it has the benefits of speed
simplicity and ease of detection and
more recently
it's become quite popular in the field
of poc or in-field diagnostics
it gives the ability for that rapid
diagnosis of whether your target
is present or absent
so when we talk about amplification
there's going to be some challenges or
key features or things that you're going
to want to consider
along the way through your assay
development so if we focus on the
performance aspect
there are going to be challenges you may
come up against regarding
accuracy or reproducibility or
specificity
and or sensitivity on the other side
or on the other hand you'll have the
operational parameters regarding your
assay
how easy is it to access your tests how
easy is it to use your test is it just
as simple as putting your sample in
and hitting a button right and of course
the time to obtaining those results how
fast and how scalable can we get those
results
from the time that we start that essay
if we take a step back at the workflow
we can see that it's connected
end to end and depending on
whether our target is dna and or rna
embedded within that sample we're going
to want to be cognizant of
what are the features or characteristics
of our sample input type
and based on that we may be able to
identify
proactively what sort of amplification
challenges we may come up against and
that's what that
middle column is really highlighting
right depending on our sample input type
do we have a limited number of sample or
amount of sample concentration of our
target within that sample
is there carryover of inhibitors do we
have dna or rna degradation
or potentially long turnaround times
right and based on those different
characteristics
we can select next generation enzymes
that have been built to proactively
address these challenges that you may
face
within your assay
so to reiterate if we look at some of
again those current challenges that
we've seen
low test sensitivity risk of degradation
long testing times and potentially
developing more complex assays that are
capable of multiplexing
we're going to want to select next
generation enzymes that have specific
phenotypes to address these challenges
and some of those phenotypes include
processivity improved processivity
speed specificity accuracy
and thermal stability
so in the following slides we're going
to cover
each of these key attributes of these
next generation enzymes
when you typically may come up against
them what that ultimately means for your
assay
and what these key attributes or
enhanced attributes
can do to improve your assay
so let's start with specificity
and generally the challenges we have
with specificity is we have non-amp
non-specific amplification of a target
we didn't intend to identify or amplify
in the first place
this comes from miss prime dna and
generally an enzyme that's active at
room temperature
right we're going to get that mixed
prime dna because we do want that
benefit
of setting up our academic temperature
so how did we get that benefit without
that misprimed amplification of a target
we didn't identify
and this is where leveraging hot start
enzymes
enzymes that are not active at room
temperature while we're setting up our
assay
leveraging those enzymes such that even
if we do get that misprimed dna
we don't detect that in a downstream
analysis right so these hot start
enzymes
are modified either through the addition
of an antibody
chemical an acid body molecule or
aptomer
rendering that enzyme inactive at room
temperature such that when we are ready
the assay is complete
and ready for cycling we can raise the
temperature
of that assay to 90 degrees activate
that enzyme
and now under those more stringent
conditions we get the annealing of our
primers to the template
at the right locations and that active
enzyme now is focused on amplifying our
target of interest
so if we jump to the next slide we have
some examples right we look at
example a on the left hand side if we
don't have a hot start enzyme
when we're setting up that reaction
we're getting that missed prime target
or miss prime targets and we're seeing
the results and amplification
of that active enzyme because it's
active at that room temperature setup
in this particular example we leverage
that hot start enzyme we follow the same
setup process
but now that enzyme is only active when
we're ready and then
through that we see that expected
amplification
and the resultant of higher yield of
that particular target of interest
and if we jump over to example b
this is highlighting the fact that
through leveraging higher
cycling temperatures we get greater
specificity
with these thermostable enzymes and as a
result it
we get a higher yield and specific
amplification of our target of interest
so now let's jump to processivity and
processivity refers to
how many nucleotides are being
incorporated within a single
binding event our enzyme binding to that
template and generally what prevents
that enzyme from
from integrating several or many on the
higher end
nucleotides in one binding event is the
presence of
inhibitors for example right they knock
that enzyme or distract that enzyme from
being able to incorporate
many nucleotides and knock the enzyme
off the template so the resultant of
that is
shorter amplicons or cdna and we get low
processivity of this enzyme
because now more enzyme binding events
have to occur
in order for us to get a full-length
cdna
so the best way to overcome this is to
leverage
enzymes that have inhibitor tolerance
and through that they're able to
incorporate
they can withstand the presence of those
inhibitors
and incorporate many nucleotides at the
same time or the same binding of that
and ultimately that means improve
processing power
which ultimately will mean for your
assay full length amplicons
and here's a great example so if you
look at example a in each of these
columns
we have a designation h which represents
a high processivity enzyme l1 l2
l3 and l4 represent low processor
enzymes
so if we focus on the first pair of
columns
we can see our high process of the
enzyme
in the presence of no inhibitor and the
banding pattern that we would expect
and the same for the low processivity
enzyme l1 and l2
as soon as we start to introduce
formalin an inhibitor
we see the banding pattern of those low
processivity enzymes start to drop off
right but consistent for our high
processivity enzyme
those that are tolerant of let's say in
this case formula
in the second set of columns and that
grouping of four
very similar concept right and the left
hand side of each of those columns we
have
our high processing the enzyme and the
expected band pattern
and l3 and l4 low processivity enzymes
and the introduction in the second third
and fourth columns
inhibitors that are all ultimately
altering the banding pattern
which dictate those enzymes are
intolerant and are incapable
of amplifying a specific target when
those inhibitors are present
if we jump to example b there's a
numerical representation of that data
right that
transcriptional efficiency that we can
see with high processivity enzymes
versus those low processivity enzymes
that are denoted
in those blue bars
so thermal stability right the lower the
temperature that we're doing our
amplification stage is at
the greater the likelihood of will come
across our enzyme will come across
secondary structures resulting in
truncated synthesis
right and this is either due to
secondary
and or high gc content so the best way
to resolve this is to
increase that temperature at which we're
doing this reaction or this reaction is
being conducted
and that requires an enzyme that's
tolerant and is able to perform
accurately and efficiently at higher
temperatures
or also known as a thermostable enzyme
right so if we look at that image
just down the center of the screen 37
degrees we have this high presence of
these secondary structures which
ultimately will result in
truncated synthesis but if we can run
that same reaction with the thermostable
enzyme
at 55 to 65 degrees we see that nice
clean single strand and that enzyme is
able to run along uninhibited
and that's what the data or the gel
image on the far right hand side is
indicating right we can run that
reaction
with a thermal stable enzyme whether at
50 degrees
all the way through 65 and we get that
nice consistent banding pattern
so now we're going to jump to accuracy
and the application of particular
relevance
let's say would be sequencing and in
this particular area
we want to maintain the integrity of the
sequence that we are ultimately
amplifying
and detecting so here we're going to
want to leverage high fidelity enzymes
with extremely low error rates right and
if you look at our benchmark
enzyme platinum superfly 2
in comparison to those that are offered
by our industry peers
you can expect up to 350 times
the accuracy as compared to the the
conventional
dna polymerase
and last but not least greater speed
right so
we want to avoid the length of time
that's required let's say in a longer
essay how do we start to improve that
improve that turnaround time so we're
not waiting an hour and potentially
maybe we can get to 20 minutes
right and in the the example on the
right hand side
we can see again a flagship enzyme our
platinum two
back hot start dna polymerase
we compare that to our industry peers
through ramping time they're fairly
similar
right but where you really start to see
that advantage is through that cycling
time
and through the course of those multiple
cycles you are now starting to cut down
the length of time the total time it
takes for you to complete that assay
and using an enzyme like this you can
achieve up to four times faster
synthesis
than conventional attack dna polymerase
so how do you know what enzyme to
leverage
right there we have next generation
enzymes that possess some or potentially
all
of these qualities but to to leverage an
enzyme that possesses all of these
qualities
it can become cost prohibitive
right so it's really critical that you
understand when we go back to that
workflow
what are the attributes or
characteristics of your sample input
type
and potentially your target and your
downstream analysis
such that you can identify what
challenges you may come up against
and which key features you need to
ensure that are built into your enzyme
so that this way whether you choose an
enzyme with
let's say all five key attributes or you
select an enzyme that has two or three
enzymes
two or three of those key features
you'll still ultimately get the same
output
at a much more costly it'll it'll be
much more cost effective
right and that's what's really critical
and just as a quick comment here
generally customers are quite curious
about you know when do i get my thermo
fisher support team
to engage in my process to help me kind
of navigate which will be
which enzymes or components become the
best fit for me
and the answer overwhelming it
overwhelmingly is
it's never too early right the earlier
we partner the earlier we start to have
those conversations and you engage
our technical and r d teams the earlier
they can advise
on what components would best suit your
particular assay
of interest such that you get off the
ground much quicker
ultimately saving you time space and
money
so if you look at protein design
and the development of this next
generation enzymes it comes from two
different sides
we have the protein design side where we
can leverage things like
rational design site-specific
mutagenesis as an example of protein
fusion
technology we can leverage
protein evolution it's directed to how
to push the enzyme to develop a specific
phenotype or characteristic
or we can go to natural sources of
biodiversity those
atypical climates defined enzymes that
perform
under unique conditions on the flip side
of that our enzymes
come with a wide variety of buffers and
that chemistry is a joint chemistry
approach
can we tweak that buffer to optimize the
activity of that enzyme
and if we take it a step further and
certainly as
the market evolves for how do we develop
let's say
enzyme that is capable of being you know
stable or good at room temperature
or creates lighter transportation costs
or can be used in the field
and this is where we start talking about
buffer formulations that have no
glycerol right and we talked about those
lyo ready products or lyell already and
bonds
if we go back again to the protein side
of developing
these next generation enzymes we can go
to natural sources and this is driven
more by luck right we go to a unique
climate
and we spontaneously identify an enzyme
that we didn't anticipate
to identify or know we were looking for
and we find something
that's naturally occurring right that's
one side of it then we can take control
and
and maybe pivot into rational design
based on our understanding of
what that enzyme looks like from a
structural perspective
how do we start to tweak that structure
by altering the amino acid composition
right and ultimately to
improve the activity of that enzyme or
change the phenotype of that enzyme
and then finally protein evolution can
we not so much by luck but direct
phenotype that potentially an enzyme
will ultimately take on
right can we put it into a high stress
high temperature situation let's say as
an example
in order to develop an enzyme that is
capable of performing
reactions at higher temperatures like
those thermal stable enzymes that i
mentioned
earlier
so here's an example of that directed
evolution
driving that enzyme to have a particular
phenotype by mutating
existing enzymes and the example here or
the the method here
being highlighted is compartmentalized
self-replication
where we leverage e coli and we have
a dna polymerase encoded gene which is
being self-replicated
under a stressful condition in this
particular case let's say
it's a highly stressful high temperature
environment right ultimately can we
drive
that e coli to self-replicate the dna
polymerase
at a high temperature create that stress
such that we only get
mutated dna polymerase that is able
able to perform that process at a high
temperature
right ultimately can we pull that clone
out and then leverage it to develop
a next generation enzyme that is highly
thermal stable
another example being the enzyme fusion
technology right so we see this in high
fidelity
dna polymerase again that would be very
relevant for sequencing
in this particular case we have combined
a a traditional dna polymerase
infuse that with a
proofreading enzyme similar to something
that we would see in a pfu dna
polymerase
which ultimately creates improved
processivity
it enhances the enzyme's ability to
process that template ultimately making
it faster
and so that's the features that we're
calling it at the bottom right we
improve that reaction speed
and increase the accuracy the fidelity
of that enzyme
by creating this fusion protein
so when we talk about advances in enzyme
development
it's a combination or it's a
multi-pronged approach
protein evolution buffer innovation
directed neogenesis and through
leveraging this multi-pronged approach
we've developed some of our most recent
cutting-edge flagship enzymes which
includes
platinum two attack hot start dna
polymerase superscript 4
reverse transcriptase and platinum super
52 our high fidelity
dna polymerase all backed by 40 years of
experience
in enzyme development and manufacturing
now that we've talked a little bit about
some of these next generation enzymes
and how they're developed
let's look at some examples that you can
start leveraging today starting with
platinum two dna polymerase this
particular enzyme possesses
hot start technology and what that means
for you as an end user is
it comes with heightened sensitivity and
specificity
meaning greater yield of your target at
target amplicon the enzyme
is activityless at room temperature
attributing to its ease of use
for room temperature setup and because
of this
specificity sensitivity and ease of use
from a setup perspective at room
temperature
you're getting this reproducibility
between your reactions and all of that
is achieved
through the antibodies that are bound to
the enzyme rendering it
activityless at room temperature until
we do that initial denaturation step
where we separate that antibody from
that enzyme bringing it to an active
state
and if we look at the examples in the
bottom right hand corner
regardless of how much template we
introduce into our reaction
we still get this nice crisp banding
across the board
and when we look at in the in the last
image in the bottom right hand corner
under column p
what this is representing is at the zero
hour time mark when we set up our
reaction at room temperature
and we run that reaction subsequently we
get a nice crisp
band if we keep that set up for 24 hours
at room temperature
we still get a nice crisp band but when
we look at enzymes that don't possess
hot start technology and we set up that
reaction and run
immediately we already start to see some
of that drop off
in our in our target anita and it's even
more so
when we hold that reaction at
temperature at room temperature for 24
hours
and run that reaction
when we look at next generation enzyme
development
if you'll remember earlier we discussed
it happens
on two sides by tweaking the enzyme
itself from a structural perspective
but also that buffer chemistry that
comes along with that enzyme
and in this particular instance by
tweaking the buffer that comes with
platinum two dna polymerase
we can start to improve the speed four
times faster than a conventional
tac dna polymerase we can start to
elevate the enzymes ability to tolerate
inhibitors
and we can also elevate the enzyme
ability to amplify
difficult and gc rich targets
and all of this attributes to time to
results
improved ease of use and versatility so
if i can draw your attention to the
bottom right hand corner of this
of this slide and we look at the gels
again we can see that
whether inhibitors are present or not
present
that enzyme is able to accurately
amplify our target amplicon
with a nice crisp band and if we look at
the bottom right
hand corner that last image and from the
left side of that last image
we have 29 gc content and on the far
right hand side
77 gc content regardless
we are seeing nice crisp consistent
banding
indicating that this enzyme is able to
perform
accurate amplification even in gc rich
targets
so if we look at now a reverse
transcriptase
and the flagship enzyme being
superscript 4 known for its high
sensitivity and robustness
this particular enzyme can reduce ct
values by as much as eight cycles
when we talk about rtq pcr it has the
added benefit of high tolerance to
inhibitors
in sample and it's super fast right 10
minutes to reaction time
the key attributes are elevated
attributes sensitivity
reproducibility time to results ease of
use and versatility
and the image i'd like to call out on
the far right hand corner
we can see superscript 3 and superscript
4
have this nice consistent banding
pattern actually between each other
when we look at some enzymes rts from
our industry peers
in columns p n t and q we start to see
some of these bands missing
and when we compare both superscripts
superscript 3 and superscript 4
we can see that improvement in this next
generation
iteration of superscript 3 being
superscript 4.
if we switch gears for a moment and
start to look at innovations and buffer
and buffer chemistry
and how we can start to tweak this
chemistry for the benefit of some of our
more
complex assays as in this case
multiplexing
how are the advancements in buffer
chemistry ultimately helping us
to create and achieve optimal result
results with some of these
trickier assays if you will and in this
instance when you're dealing with
multiple prime repairs one of the
biggest challenges is going to be
how can you quickly calculate what that
optimal annealing temperature needs to
be for your prime repairs so that
you're able to amplify your targets
without compromise
and as you can see here by tweaking that
buffer chemistry
and in this instance developing a buffer
that is capable
of enabling all of our prime repairs to
universally anneal at a temperature of
60 degrees celsius
without sacrificing the amplification of
any one of our given targets
now we are starting to elevate the
performance of our enzymes in our
reactions
through ease of use again specificity
multiplexing and versatility and that's
what that image is showing you on the
bottom right hand corner
right across the board for each of our
target amplicons
all of them are being amplified nice
crisp and clear
without compromise
so again i think the key here is
focusing maybe on the bottom half of
this screen
right again the topic being multiplexing
and when we look at a variety of
infectious targets
whether viral and bacterial which come
with their own nuances
and if we look maybe even specifically
within bacterial
gram-positive and gram-negative both
with their own nuances
and as we go along how do we
leverage buffer chemistry and treat that
buffer chemistry such that we can look
at
these variety of targets with their own
nuances and still get
nice specific amplification and that's
what that gel
is showing you on the right hand side
right whether we have one target
we introduce two and we jump all the way
to 15
all of those bands stay consistent
across the board
if we take buffer chemistry one step
further and start to talk about
some of these more recent market trends
maybe past 12 or 18 months or so
point-of-care diagnostics leveraging
assays and cartridges
but even how do we eliminate cold
transport or cold storage or extend
shelf life
this is where lyophilization compatible
assays
and as an extension lyophilization
compatible enzymes come into play
and existing buffers contain glycerol
which makes them incompatible with
lyophilization
so can we develop buffer and buffer
chemistries
that don't possess glycerol without
compromising the performance of our
enzymes
and we offer these liar ready options
for our reverse transcriptases our
polymerases
our master mixes as well as our pcr
enhancers
like ribolock inhibitor
so in this second last section we'll
start to see some of these next
generation enzymes in action
let's start with rtqpcr so in this
particular assay
this group wanted to develop an assay
that could be leveraged in
a microfluidic based cartridge
and right off the bat what that demands
is by optimization compatible components
we may be dealing with sample input
types that are
that have inhibitors that are present
right we're dealing with saliva
potentially blood samples
which also comes with potentially low
target
in our sample and if it's going to be
something that's leveraging a cartridge
potentially
at point of care airports
stadiums we're going to need something
quite fast
so in this example we have two targets
in this duplex reaction
para influenza and coronavirus and we
can see that by pairing
platinum2 attack hot start dna
polymerase
in a lyophilization compatible format
and in vitrogens superscript
one-step rtq pcr reverse transcriptase
also in a lyophilization compatible
format
we see that we can get great
amplification
and detection of both of our targets
without compromise and when we compare
that
with some of the options that are
available on the market from some of our
industry peers
the performance is head and shoulders
above
right demonstrating fast highly
efficient and robust amplification
of our viral rna targets
in our second example this particular
group
was leveraging a crispr fluorescence
detection system in order to detect the
presence
of their target through a qualitative
amplification
right so in this case and very popular
for point of care settings
so in this particular instance again
point of care
we're looking at tricky samples right
with potentially inhibitors
saliva and blood we're gonna need
something that's inhibitor tolerant
superscript four is the standout choice
and because of the specificity that is
required
for our guide rna and cast 12a
complex partnered with that fluorescent
probe the specificity that is required
for that complex
to detect that target of interest we're
going to need a high fidelity enzyme a
proof leading enzyme
and in this case the flagship enzyme
being platinum super phi 2
dna polymerase right to preserve that
sequence such that we get accurate
detection
cleavage of our pro and subsequent
detection
all of which in a live ready format so
that it can be leveraged in a point of
care setting
in this third example another really hot
topic
right isothermal amplification very
similar concept
great for utility in the field for point
of care settings
again we're going to be dealing with
potentially trickier samples
inhibitors superscript 4
rt will be the enzyme of choice and
leveraging
an isothermal enzyme in this case a bsm
dna polymerase create all of which in a
lie already format
in our last example variant sequencing
for stars coke ii lots of activity in
this area as well
so again we're going to be leveraging
superscript 4
rt kind of overcome any of those initial
challenges that we have with
our sample input type but then again the
focus being
we need to preserve the integrity
of those sequences across our samples
using a high fidelity proofreading
enzyme in this case
platinum 2 superfly 2 being the enzyme
of choice
very fast highly efficient and robust
amplification of our target
so in our last section we'll talk a
little bit about the quality
and manufacturing capabilities of thermo
fisher scientific
all of which can be leveraged by our
customers so that they do not have to
invest in those infrastructure
themselves so if you look at your
journey
from starting on the bench all the way
through to
getting onto the market you're going to
have this feasibility and developmental
stage
and this is where engaging your thermal
fissure team is going to be really
critical
the commercial team the r d team
the technical teams these teams will
guide you and advise you on
based on the parameters of your assay
and your long term
goal to getting onto market they'll
advise you on what components really
make the most sense or which ones are
worth kind of streamlining your focus on
right so it'll accelerate your time in
this phase
that'll help you get to verification
much quicker
to get that design lock in place and now
you can start to think about
what do i need from a supply chain
perspective right are the existing
formats that i'm sourcing
through the catalog sufficient or are
there
alternate formats that i could use that
are more conducive
for my manufacturing or my commercial
service
right and all of that setup is going to
come in handy when
you enter the regulatory phase and
eventually
when you hit the market
so this is an image of our site in
vilnius lithuania
it is our center of excellence for
enzymology
over 40 years of experience in enzyme
development
and it's supported by over 1400
colleagues of ours
the facility possesses all of the
regulatory standards needed for the
production of these components
and namely i'd call out iso 9001 and iso
13485 among a few others
and here's just a nice table indicating
when these
certifications were first granted and
registered and that they're
regularly kept up to date
when we talk about product delivery and
delivering the best product
for your business for your assay
we can start to look at our kits and
customize those existing kits adding
components dropping components
we can even develop kits that don't
exist at all
right totally custom kits we can break
down these kits such that we offer
standalone components and we can even
take all of that a step further
by tweaking the format
the chemistry right whether it's size or
the chemistry from a
lie already perspective and potentially
even
dna-free iterations of these components
for those highly sensitive assays
all of which is not totally inclusive
but are fair examples
of how we can tweak these components to
better fit your needs
all together when we talk about thermo
fisher scientific as your partner in
molecular assay development
leverage the businesses experience to
accelerate the time spent
in those early developmental stages
take advantage of that wide breadth and
depth
of components that are offered through
the portfolio
take it a step further with integrated
and customized solutions that best fit
your business and commercial service or
product
and last but not least
using cutting-edge components
such that the technology you develop
stays on the bleeding edge
and throughout this entire process
working with your business development
manager
to keep that process from start to
finish seamless
that you can focus on your success
i'll pause there and open it up for some
questions
thank you nayeem for your informative
presentation
before we begin the q a session please
turn your attention to the poll
questions displayed on your screen
your participation your participation is
appreciated
the first is are you currently or
planning to
commercialize a product for service
next would you like to receive a quote
from thermo fisher scientific and
finally
for further assay development needs
would you like to be contacted by a
thermo fisher scientific
business development manager
we will now start the q and a portion of
the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
great presentation and thank you i have
been designing
an rt qpcr assay using template from
culture cells
and we'll start testing blood samples
should i redesign my assay since the
quality of the template may be subpar
great question i'm glad you enjoyed the
webinar
as i mentioned in the presentation blood
samples may contain components
such as hemon that could reduce the
sensitivity of your rtqpcr assay
i'd recommend choosing sample
preparation methods specifically
designed for blood samples and for the
rtq-pcr
assay i'd recommend using superscript 4
reverse transcriptase and platinum 2-tac
dna polymerase both of these enzymes are
highly tolerant of inhibitors
in case the sample preparation was not
as robust
thank you naim our next question is
i have developed an rtq pcr master mix
using superscript reverse transcriptase
and platinum tac dna polymerase
can i lyophilize this master mix or do i
need to use a lyo ready
enzyme mentioned in your presentation
another great question so in the case of
both of these enzymes the buffer
contains glycerol
and unfortunately the ple the presence
of that glycerol is ultimately what
makes
these particular enzymes and the buffers
incompatible with lyophilization
so you'll need to remove the glycerol
from the master mix which
is extremely difficult but the good news
is
both of these enzymes come in a format
that is lyophilization compatible
both superscript rt and the platinum tag
dna polymerase
and you can expect to get similar
performance
in using the liar ready format with
little optimization
great thanks again naeem it looks like
we have time for one more question
thank you for your talk i like the idea
of eliminating the sample preparation
step
especially when i'm starting with low
amount of template in cerebrospinal
fluid
which enzymes do you recommend for
real-time pcr
fa and do you have samples that i can
test
you're absolutely welcome and thank you
so much for attending if you're planning
to minimize the sample prep step
then i would highly recommend using
enzymes with
high sensitivity again such as platinum
two-tac dna polymerase
if you're starting with an rna target
then certainly i'd suggest including
superscript 4 reverse transcriptase both
of these enzymes
have the highest sensitivity highly
tolerant of inhibitors
with the added benefit of speed we can
certainly offer you some samples to test
both in glycerol or lyo ready formats
for more information or requesting for
samples
please go to thermofisher.com forward
slash
oem enzymes
thank you again naeem for your time
today we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye